[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time to see then what is
making the headlines with the politics
editor for the online magazine galdem
latvia mclean and the chief executive of
conservative home mark wallace welcome
to both of you
so from pages then let's take a look
shall we starting with
the eye
though boris johnson has insisted fuel
supplies could soon be back to normal
the eye predicts cues could continue for
days to come
the times goes further suggesting the
disruption at the pumps could last for a
month the prime minister is now in a
battle to save christmas according to
the daily mail which says lorry driver
shortages and supply chain chaos could
ruin festivities
as reports emerge of fistfights at
petrol stations the metro declares we've
had our fill
the telegraph meanwhile reporting on
renewed tensions between the french and
british governments over who has the
right to fish in uk waters
the guardian is reporting the labour
leader secure stamina will use his
conference speech tomorrow to say the
government are lost in the woods
according to the financial times the
chair of america's central bank the
federal reserve has warned that the u.s
government risks running out of money if
it's shuts down later this week
so let's get the thoughts then of maya
and mark welcome to both of you um moya
let's go to the eye first of all then uh
despite first uh the transport secretary
and then the prime minister with the
central message that the situation is
stabilizing the eye suggesting cues
could last for days and the times we got
a glimpse of there suggesting a month um
presumably everybody just wishing this
away now
it certainly seems like it i think in
the the first place like something gran
shap said today was that uh only 37 of
pumps were no longer running dry the
fact that even 37 of pumps could even be
considered to be running dry is a
travesty um and we've seen so many cases
across the uk with this fuel shortage
key workers saying they cannot get to
their workplaces we've had stories about
carers who can't go and care for
residents in them private areas and not
private areas rural areas um we've seen
just the disasters it's caused it's
affected things outside of people
traveling in cars too so you you see
these cues on the road these
long lines of traffic people start who
are taking public transport like buses
are stuck in them as well it's been
absolute chaos and i think no amount of
wishing away is going to make us forget
it in a hurry at least i hope it won't
yes and this leads to all sorts of
questions that so far the government is
batting off for example on immigration
which we'll come to in a bit mark but
also on that issue raised by moya about
key workers um not necessary for the
moment presumably just hoping that this
will come to a natural end as as they
put it tanks are full
well i think
there are some you know pretty
fundamental reasons why a crisis like
this
kind of panic by a rush like this even
with some real constraints on supply and
delivery is to a certain extent time
limited the first reason for it is
how much space does your average person
have to keep on storing more and more
petrol you know compare it to say the
toilet roll rush um of early in the
pandemic last year when again you had
enough toilet roll in the country you
know problems with supply getting it to
the shops but just about everybody has
space to store weeks and weeks and weeks
worth of toilet rolls somewhere in their
house it's kind of easily stackable and
squishable petrol not so much you fill
up your tank maybe you've got a petrol
can with a few liters you could fill in
after that point you just start running
out of places to put to put the stuff
mercifully um the interesting question
then is are there some of these queues
that are being made up of people for
example who are topping up relatively
small amounts because they're worried
about the idea of forthcoming shortages
you know one of the ideas i've heard
floated in the last few days is the idea
not just for say a maximum spend on a
full court but a minimum spend to stop
someone say joining a queue and then
putting five six seven quids worth of
petrol just to fill up the very top of
their tank but
it does seem like while some of this
shortage has been a real delivery
problem obviously a lot of it's been
panic buying and there is a limit to how
much you can keep on panic buying petrol
you can't just keep it in a bin bag
somewhere
yeah but you panic by because you know
other people will go and get fuel so
it's it's this self-fulfilling property
and the question is do you do you blame
people for doing it
um is that the right way to to try and
calm behaviors and certainly some
behavioral psychologists suggest not
maya
well i completely agree you can't blame
the public for panicking when there's a
clear fuel shortage in the first place
a government source said today that 16
of all petrol stations were now fully
supplied with fuel that does suggest to
me there's been a fuel crisis and we
know it i think to deny that anything
has gone on is to say is doing the same
as the government is doing which is
trying to pull the wall over what we're
seeing in front of us the petrol station
right outside my house has a little sign
up saying pumps empathy shop open that
is not a sign of just people panic
buying
yeah i mean in fairness i
i didn't say that there hadn't been any
uh delivery problem obviously if pumps
are running
running dry and you have literally a
distribution problem when i said that
like the toilet roll supply
issue it wasn't the case that the
nation's stock didn't exist the issues
about those
in those supply chains about getting the
deliveries in time and then when you
have a perfectly you know a rational
response to somebody doing it you know
anyone including people in government
doing the corporal jones don't panic
don't panic it's totally rational for
people to then think well i want to get
in before this becomes a bigger problem
at which point demand spikes to 400 more
than normal interestingly tomorrow's
papers suggest it's down to somewhere
like 60 more than normal which is going
to continue to pose some problems but
clearly is a sign of what i was just
saying which is that ultimately people
run out of space to fill with their car
with petrol in most cases yeah and
certainly it does appear that uh traffic
is getting lighter as more people decide
again to work from home but you know the
pictures in the metro
uh some of the uh
you know minor elements of presume of
violence um there
uh as you can see we said this is the
one earlier isn't it this is uh somebody
wielding a knife
um
you know i mean very awkward and
dangerous situations grant chaps also
saying today that taking water bottles
to petrol stations is dangerous and
extremely unhelpful as people try and
fill whatever
methods they can the sales of jerrycans
increasing too but the broader bits that
you mentioned picked up by the daily
mail mark boris in a battle to save
christmas the broader issue if there is
no
uh fuel shortage whether or not there's
a fuel crisis uh is that there is a
shortage of hgv drivers and that has a
real knock on
in many sectors and this short term
three-month waiver of the visa is not
going to cut it
well
so so the experts in the in the field
say and you know the fact is that for
the government and you know politically
speaking these are the basic literally
bread and butter issues of day-to-day
life and they are the kind of things
where you know frankly if system is
running well it's running properly
people don't notice it and they take it
for granted but that's how things ought
to be as soon as things start to slide
particularly when you get into um
questions of supply problems affecting
christmas and so on that becomes you
know it affects millions of people
negatively and as a direct result it
becomes a major political threat you
know we already have issues around the
rising living's been warning about for
for some months and the government needs
to grip that and grip it fast
well after days of panic over petrol
stocks uh the prime minister said he was
working on the necessary preparations to
get the uk through the festive season
and beyond grant shap suggesting uh the
bringing in the army to familiarize
themselves with the distribution of fuel
was the 18th different separate measure
they brought in so far stretching right
back to the spring and the question i
suppose now moya is whether the the
people um have confidence in these
mechanisms to halt difficulties
well i mean they haven't holded any
difficulties so what mechanisms are
really in place i also think it's
very ironic that the government are
offering paltry
three-month visas to about five thousand
foreign drivers to try and tempt them
back to the uk after measures they
bought in the first place which means
they could no longer work in the uk and
now these drivers along with drivers who
already based in the uk say that they're
not gonna do it because conditions are
just too poor for h htv drivers in this
in this country um
they were talking about conditions over
in europe where you know you you can you
have you don't have to pay to sleep you
can you have spaces to fill up it's a
lot more comfortable the pay is higher
and i think it just speaks to a general
neglect of workers that we've seen over
the last few months especially
throughout the pandemic
and too little too late on part of the
government who don't care enough and
then by when we're in crisis they're
suddenly scrambling to make it up and
it's just not good enough yes we saw
issues with care workers getting to
people they need to look after cancer
appointments as well delayed by the fuel
crisis uh according to the daily
telegraph um but when you go back to the
message from the government just go
about your businesses as you would
normally and all of this will calm down
are you optimistic mark
well yeah i i
optimistic is a strong word after the
last 18 months that we've all had but
you know
ultimately some of these things will
be resolved by practical action some of
them will be resolved um frustratingly
uh by
by time and as you were saying earlier
that psychological question how do you
deal with a panic in a shortage and uh
your challenges can happen for a number
of different reasons they can be real to
some degree
and then the fear of them that sparks
perfectly logical for individuals
um then makes them even even more acute
and as i was saying earlier simply
saying you know don't panic don't panic
it seems to me like precisely the right
way to make people panic more so um
we are in a fix and it's going to take
some time to work itself out of course
you know add in there's just been a
global plague which is going to have its
own knock-on effects as we all know on
all sorts of different manufacturing
supply chains delivery all sorts of
parts of the economy too
well lots of discussion about this no
doubt we'll have more on that later this
hour as well but plenty more still to
come maybe a little bit look at the
papers with the pictures of bond but
also secure stamina to set up his vision
for how labour would govern britain
[Music]
everyone will be taking a lateral flow
test and we will be checking that at
registration when they pick their
running number um and in picking up
their running number they're going to
hand over their the bag of the kits that
they want to wear once they've finished
this means that we have more space at
the finish area on the mouth and at the
start what we've done is put everyone
into
uh 40 over 40 different waves of runners
um so that we've spread the start over
an hour and a half so the course will be
less crowded um and uh
this is outdoors everyone will have had
this lateral flow test huge amount of
money being raised for charity and
outdoors is the best place you could
possibly be we've had an incredibly
difficult last 20 months um we've been
in our homes we've been missing being
with people we've been a part that sense
of community has been lost
and i think that uh
with all the procedures that we've put
in place and we work with the government
the events research program that we put
in place
for an event that took place at kempton
park back in may then we did one in in
july the first closed road event in
london later on in july and then the
vitality big half in august we've been
gradually testing various procedures
getting these events bigger and we are
very confident with what we're doing and
people doing these events have been so
happy to be able to be together to feel
safe and to get that incredible sense of
community
it is truly an amazing place to to come
to to visit i'm near canada gate you
might be able to hear the canada geese
behind me um yeah and we've got elite
athletes uh we charted a plane from
kenya in ethiopia that arrived at
heathrow this morning so the uh late
athletes have started to come in and and
again it is uh you know we've got david
weir uh the greatest
uh athlete in the world in terms of uh
the london marathon he won the mini
marathon six times he's won the marathon
eight times he'll be back and uh yeah
we're just so delighted to be um to be
part of this uh this event is back after
889 days
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now moya lothian mclean
and mark wallace welcome back to both of
you um so uh the guardian uh one of the
only newspapers to lead on secure
stammer his moment of glory uh on
wednesday didn't manage an in-person
conference speech last year of course
what's his job moya what does he need to
do
oh god uh
he has a mountain to climb i think
perhaps even a larger mountain than the
one he inherited in 2019 because uh he
is now much as dama
used to talk about unity he is now
tellingly according to his age replace
the word unity with winning in this
speech
but in the process has abandoned all
attempts at unity within the party and
much as he might try and pretend
otherwise he is handling a party
bitterly divided and looks to have no
plan whatsoever to bring them both back
together and
communicate a clear vision to the
country it's a lot of talk and hot air
at the moment and what does he need to
do
to shake off carbonism um because that's
what the guardian suggests is his aim is
after that terrible dropping in the last
election
well i think he's had more than a year's
shake of corbinism i mean jeremy corbyn
isn't he's not even a part he's he's
lost the labour whip so we're still
talking about carbonism but starmah has
yet to set out any staminism you can't
just keep going i'm going to stop
talking about this i'm going to stop
talking about this and not set out
another
a set of a clear winning vision that um
puts your stamp all over it so maybe to
stop talking about causes he should
start to stop talking about it and set
out his own plan very quickly mark
so yeah very quickly the difficulty
kieva really has is that his strategy is
to basically be
slow and quiet not particularly
interesting things he's relatively well
suited to and hope that in time
the government kind of messes up so
badly that he becomes a viable
alternative and
firstly it hasn't quite worked so far
luck not being particularly good at
politics whatever you attribute it to
but in the meantime his party is getting
incredibly impatient and fractious and
suspicious of him as we've seen
in the last couple of days and i think
he's really going to struggle given his
performance so far to keep a lid on
those pressures long enough
for that strategy to eventually have a
chance of bearing fruit